en el vídeo anterior deducimos la
fórmula para la suma de una serie
geométrica finita verdad y que aquí
estoy o aquí escribí antes de empezar el
vídeo donde a es nuestro primer término
y r es la proporción común ahora lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es pensar en
algo que es realmente impactante es muy
impresionante y es pensar en una serie
geométrica
pero infinita ok entonces esto yo creo
que es impresionante porque una suma
infinita nos puede dar algo finito
dependiendo de cómo sea nuestra
proporción común y hay varias formas de
pensarlo la primera es pensar que esto
en realidad es el límite límite si
queremos pensar como una serie infinita
podemos pensar que es el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito n tiende a infinito de
esto que tenemos acá arriba la suma
desde que acá vale cero hasta n
de a por ere a la k muy bien entonces
estamos calculando la misma serie
geométrica pero ahora estamos
permitiendo que la n crezca y crezca y
crezca tanto como nosotros queramos muy
bien entonces esto como es una igualdad
será igual al límite al límite cuando n
n si estamos jugando con la n cuando n
tiende a infinito de esta fórmula que ya
teníamos acá arriba a menos a por ere a
la n 1 muy bien todo esto dividido entre
1 - r y ahí lo tienen entonces sólo
tenemos que pensar cuánto vale este
límite y te invito a que hagas una pausa
y que pienses cuánto va a valer esto y
te voy a dar una sugerencia piensa para
las las erres o
o más bien piensa qué pasa para cuando
el valor absoluto de r nuestra
proporción común es más grande que uno
piensa cuando vale exactamente 1 y qué
pasa cuando es más chico que 1
ok piensa cuando tenemos esos tres casos
del valor absoluto de r
ok entonces voy a suponer que ya hiciste
una pausa ya lo pensaste ahora vamos a
hacerlo todos juntos bueno primero que
pasa si el valor absoluto de r si el
valor absoluto de r es mayor que 1 en
este caso este término que tenemos aquí
a ponerle a la n 1 va a tener un valor
absoluto que va creciendo cada vez más a
medida que n va creciendo entonces este
numerador va a tener digamos un valor
absoluto muy muy muy muy grande y si
tiene un valor absoluto muy muy grande
entonces este límite es infinito
entonces no nos dice mucho la fórmula
que pasa si el valor absoluto es igual a
1 igual a 1 si tenemos que esto vale
igual a 1
entonces fíjate que de aquí que esto que
es el denon el denominador es un cero y
eso ya tampoco tiene sentido porque
estamos dividiendo entre cero y eso no
se puede así que vamos a pensar el caso
en que es realmente interesante
da mucha información de cómo se comporta
esta serie y es cuando el valor absoluto
de r es más chico que 1 y por supuesto
tiene que ser mayor que 0 porque dijimos
que r no podía ser 0 muy bien entonces
regresemos a este término
este término o bueno pensemos sólo en
este cierre tiene un valor absoluto más
chico que 1 y más grande que 0 entonces
a medida que vamos elevando a las
potencias n más uno y vamos haciendo que
la n sea cada vez más grande y más
grande entonces éste va a tener un valor
absoluto cada vez más pequeño piensa por
ejemplo en un medio cuando elevamos al
cuadrado se vuelve un cuarto cuando
elevamos al cubo se vuelve un octavo
ahora piensa que estamos elevando a la c
un medio a la 100 o un medio al
1.000.000 o al a un billón entonces esto
de aquí este término a por r a la n 1 en
realidad tiende a cero cuando metemos ya
este límite cuando hacemos
cuando n tiende a infinito entonces cuál
es el resultado si esto se hace cero
simplemente nos queda a entre 1 - cr
1 - ser muy bien entonces piensa ahora
vamos a hacer un ejemplo que tal que
tenemos uno más un tercio más un tercio
al cuadrado más un tercio al cubo y así
sumamos todas las potencias de un tercio
muy bien entonces por supuesto aquí
tenemos una proporción común más chica
que uno entonces podemos aplicar esta
fórmula muy bien y esto sería
exactamente el primer término que es uno
sería uno entre uno menos la proporción
común si vamos a ponerlo en verde
1 - la proporción común que es un tercio
y esto simplemente nos queda 1 entre 1
menos un tercio son dos tercios y uno
entre dos uno entre dos tercios es tres
medios entonces tuvimos una suma
infinita y a pesar de eso lo que tenemos
es que el valor de esa suma es finito